[Musique]
la position des républicains était
toujours dû arrêter de considérer que
effectivement les seuls chômage doit
être réformé en france il n'ya plus
d'écart suffisant entre celui qui ne
travaille pas et celui qui travaille et
tout le monde est perdant
celui qui ne travaille pas parce qu'il
n'est pas inciter à les travailler celui
qui travaille parce qu'il est désespéré
d'aller travailler les chefs
d'entreprises et des artisans qui
n'arrivent pas à recruter tant que nous
ne recréerons pas un écart fondamental
entre les revenus de l'assistance et les
revenus du travail
la france économiquement sera lancée le
gouvernement est trop forte qu'annoncée
et puis une fille née on a une toute
petite refn quelle est la situation de
la sécurité dans notre pays
quelle est la situation face à laquelle
se trouvent nos forces de l'ordre auquel
je veux rendre hommage parce qu'elles
sont admirables de courage on a eu 34
suicides de policiers depuis le 1er
janvier
34 c'est à dire le même nombre que pour
toute l'année 2018
il y à une pression maximale sur nos
forces de l'ordre la violence augmente
on l'a vu dans l'arrivée de 2012 ça y
est qu'ils ont voulu je propose
aujourd'hui c'est une grande loi de
programmation parce que d'abord y manque
des moyens
il manque de moyens donc il faut donner
des moyens budgétaires supplémentaires à
nos policiers à nos gendarmes ont trouvé
je dois vous dire qui elle accueille sur
son sol et nous plaidions également pour
l'instauration d'un débat sur
l'immigration à chaque rentrée le
présent la république a annoncé à
l'automne un premier ministre plus
précisément annoncée à l'automne la
tenue d'un débat au parlement sur les
questions migratoires
je pense que c'est bien mais je lui
promet de beaux jours parce que dans la
loi asile immigration qui est une belle
cure parlement qu'est ce qu'on a vu on a
vu que sur ces questionnements
pollutions l'immigration très largement
la majorité à gauche un peu de calme on
n'est pas obligés de céder à la panique
on n'est pas obligé de céder à la menace
qu'est ce qui rejoint la république en
marche et mâcon cèdent à la panique
ben oui cent des élections européennes
et en perspective une élection
municipale ya rien de plus opposé qu'une
élection européenne élections
municipales
je pense qu'ils sont une espèce de feu
riposte européenne se disant les
républicains ont fait un très mauvais
score
ce qui est vrai la droite ne pèse plus
que 8 % dans l'échiquier politique dont
on reste partagé les dépouilles en
réalité ils méconnaissent c'est bien la
première tuner connaissent le niveau
local parce que une élection municipale
c'est une fête une une règle tout à fait
différente
c'est un enjeu local pour l'essentiel
les maires mettent carrément en avant
des risques et politique mais plutôt des
bilans et des projets la question de
cette convention du 6 juillet que je
souhaite c'est j'en ai un peu assez de
dire je ne suis pas madame le pen et je
ne suis pas monsieur macron j'ai envie
de dire qui nous sommes
parce que je pense que nous nous avons
une identité nous sommes le parti de la
liberté et de la responsabilité dont
pour m
[Musique]